forch.
[Silence]
Subhan Allah.
Subhanahu Waala.
[Silence]
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Notice
the way these verses are structured
and the idea here is that we're
trying to go through the Quran
based on the order of revelation. So I'm
going to say this now every night except
for Saturday night. Saturday night we do
the questions and answers
but the rest of the nights Wednesday
Thursday Friday Sunday
we are going through the Quran in the
order of revelation
we're not trying to get through the
whole thing we're not trying to go fast
and go through the verses we're trying
to take it slow and take the most
relevant aspects of it so we will go
through surah Al then next we will move
to
then after that we will move to M and
I'll give you the chapters as we go
through them if you want to benefit from
these talks these classes these these
these lectures these whatever you want
to call them if you really want to
benefit
then you read these verses you keep up
with where we are you might think
we're going kind of slow and then we'll
speed up in some places because the idea
is not just to cover ground. The idea is
we're trying to take the details of
these verses
in the order that they were revealed to
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. So as
we take these verses we're going through
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
At the same time, we've noticed almost
for two weeks or even longer, we've been
on those first five verses. Why? Because
there are so many introductory
pieces of information that we need in
order to proceed and understand these
verses in their proper context. You can
also go back and refer to these talks
that we have been going through every
night on the Facebook page. All of them
are there. They're archived. You can go
back and listen to them and try to
take the knowledge or whatever you
missed or review and what have you. And
then sometimes we'll go off topic
because we have other issues to deal
with as they arise. But that is the
plan. Notice these verses that Allah
says mentions in this chapter.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
in spite of all of Allah's mercy and
generosity and forgiveness and grace the
human being will invariably
invariably
he will
overstep his bounds
and he used the word what insan
Because the word insan
elicits a lot of descriptions Allah has
given that name alins
in
Allah says in the Quran indeed the human
being is oppressive and ever ungrateful.
And another verse
in
the human being is very ignorant and
insists upon ignorance and is satisfied
with his ignorance. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala refers to the human being as
the human being is so hasty it's as if
he has been created from haste itself.
He is the embodiment of haste and a lack
of patience. So when Allah says insan
anywhere in the Quran all of these
descriptions come the son of Adam
the story of Adam
of Allah upon us
and
the
the name.
He
being
creature
and creat
apes and animals. We are special
creatures created for paradise in
paradise itself.
He says subhanahua.
So he created the human being from a
clinging clot of blood in the mother's
womb. It started as drops, secretions,
and then Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala grew
it and cultivated it into a clot. And
then Allah cultivated it with such
perfection, with such balance,
with such incredible attention.
If just one little thing is off, it's
not a creation. Perfection monitored at
every moment from the moment of his
conception. The human being is watched
and monitored by Allah and he goes
through these stages
and then the human being is brought into
this world
and the human being is given and fed and
taught until he grows and he is now able
to walk on his legs. He's able to stand
upright. He's able to speak. He's able
to feel emotions that are so deep and he
is able to conceptualize
concepts that are abstract
and he's able to communicate these
things to other human beings. Human
being is an incredible creature that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has endowed
with so much potential.
He says,
"Read, recite, and your Lord is
generous.
Continue to seek that knowledge from
your Lord and he is always more generous
than his servant will ever be." And so
he reciprocates our efforts. Subhan
is the one who taught by the pen. He
made the human being as a what? He said
in the first story he mentions in the
Quran he said to the angels
I'm going to place a successor in the
earth. Who is this successor? What does
that mean? successor.
One who succeeds another comes after
another and carries the
formentioned or the the carries the
the former
on. He is a continuation. He is a
successor.
This means two things. Number one, we
succeed one another.
We all as a people learn and then we
document what we learn and we pass it on
to the next generation. They don't have
to start back at zero. They don't have
to reinvent the wheel. They are able to
what? Build on what we already built.
And then the next generation is able to
and he gave us the ability to write that
and communicate thoughts across
thousands of years.
Can you imagine? You know how we
human beings are constantly fantasizing
in movies and TV shows about you know
a person who can control people's
minds or a person who can you know
telepathically
speak to another without using their
mouth and their words. Human beings do
something much greater than that.
We have the ability to think a thought,
learn a piece of information, write it,
document it, and thousands of years
later, I am still communicating those
ideas and words into the minds of
others. That's an incredible amount of
power that the human being has.
Also,
look at how much care Allah gives the
human being. He wrote in the preserved
tablet our
decree. Every one of us, every single
one of us, how many breaths you're going
to take, how many hairs are on your
body, how many thoughts will go through
your mind, how many times your heart
will beat.
He subhanahu wa ta'ala wrote all of that
in the preserved tablet
50,000
years before the first creation.
He wrote by the pen.
He says
he taught the human being what he did
not know. After all of that,
what does what are the next verses?
Indeed, the human being in spite of all
that
will overstep his bounds, will disobey
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Now Allah
gives us not just the the he doesn't
just give us the diagnosis
he gives us the medicine
and he also gives us the medicine
with the diagnosis
and as they say knowing what the illness
is
is half of the medicine but the other
half is he diagnoses the essence essence
of our problems. He doesn't just
diagnose and treat the symptoms.
He gets to the root of the issue. When
Allah says all this, look at all of
these great endowments Allah has placed
in the human being. How much potential
how much the human being is is how much
potential the human being has been
endowed with. In spite of all that,
you'd think the human being would be
grateful. No, the human being will
indeed invariably
overstep his bounds and disobey. Why?
What's the real cause of that? That's
that's the diagnosis. That's the
illness. Overstepping our bounds. What's
the reason behind all overstepping of
bounds? All of them
is because the human being sees himself
as independent and not in need.
That's why that's why
every person when the angel of death
comes for him believes in Allah repents
and and and concedsahill
even down
Pharaoh. His last words were,
"I believe in what believe in."
So he
concedes that none is rightfully
worshiped but Allah and I believe.
Why did that arrogant arrogant man
believe at that moment? Because the
illusion was gone and he sees how in
need he is of Allah.
Why did he not say that before?
because the illusion was that he didn't
need Allah in that moment. Things were
good. So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
he didn't say
[Silence]
And so the root cause of the human being
overstepping
is that the illusion convinces him and
deludes him into thinking that he
doesn't need anyone else. He doesn't
need Allah at that moment.
He doesn't need to worship Allah.
That's why he oversteps.
And every one of us, no matter how
slight our disobedience of Allah is, if
you really look at yourself and say, "I
just messed up. I just sinned. Why did
that sin happen? It was because we felt
at that moment that we didn't need
anything. We were happy and so we were
enjoying ourselves in Allah's
disobedience.
The illusion convinced us that we didn't
need at that moment.
And so the root cause of all
disobedience
is that a person deludes himself or
allows the dunya to cover his eyes and
make him think that he doesn't need he
doesn't need Allah at that moment
at that second but the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam would say
every morning and every night.
Every morning he'd wake up and every
night when the sun would go down he
would say
he would make dua. Oh Allah, I beg of
you, do not place me in charge of my own
affairs. Not even for the blink of an
eye ever.
Always you, Allah, be the disposer of my
affairs and the rectifier of my affairs.
So we understand from this that what
really separates the believer from the
disbeliever
is that the disbeliever in times of
difficulty
he the illusion is gone he sees that he
needs Allah he turns to Allah in
difficulty but then when he's given ease
he forgets Allah why because the
illusion convinces him that he doesn't
need Allah at that moment
He he he's independent. The believer is
different. How is the believer
different? He is able to see through
that illusion in times of ease and
difficulty.
And so he knows that he needs Allah in
times of ease and difficulty.
And the worship of Allah in times of
ease are far more superior than the
worship of Allah in times of difficulty.
Because everyone worships Allah in times
of difficulty. It's the times of ease
when people forget Allah. The believer
continues to remember how in need of
Allah he is at every moment.
Subhanahu
Subhanahu Waala